[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition de
votre rendez-vous infoloisirs sur terré
60,18 le 7-8 week end avec aujourd'hui à
la france qui se prépare à une nouvelle
étape du déconfinement le 19 mai le
couvre feu sera repoussé à 21h cinémas
lieux culturels commerce terrasses des
restaurants vont progressivement
accueillir à nouveau du public et nous
irons dans une auberge et dans un peuple
justement et qui dans les yvelines sont
déjà prêts côté actualité nous parlerons
également de l'ombre de michel fourniret
qui planent toujours sur les yvelines le
tueur en série décédé en début de
semaine emporté avec lui à plusieurs
secrets sur des affaires en cours et
plusieurs concernent le département et
puis pour la partie loisirs de ce
magazine direction le château de
breteuil et ses visites en extérieur
mais aussi maurepas pour un mais dessert
à distance cette fois ci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la réouverture des terrasses de café bar
restaurant est donc confirmée pour le 19
mai une jauge de 50% de la capacité
d'accueil a été fixé pour les plus
grands établissements il faudra
également être assis et ne pas être plus
de 6 à table malgré ces contraintes les
professionnels semblent plutôt est
satisfait il s'adapte une nouvelle fois
reportage à voisins le bretonneux de
nicolas landry et bérangère bourgoin
kong où il croisera t on à déjà commencé
à mettre en place notre terrasse on à la
distanciation absolument partout on a
plus d'un mètre vingt ou un mètre
cinquante d'entre shakhtar voilà comment
s'organise la terrasse de la ferme de
voisins comme beaucoup de restaurateurs
romain gicquel doit jongler entre les
différentes mesures sanitaires mais il
reste confiant quant au 19 mai nous
ouvrons la terrasse si le temps le
permet nous allons continuer le click
and collect et à partir du 9 juin
nous ouvrons l'intérieur du restaurant
donc midi et soir sont moins cette
période de fermeture a été mise à profit
par la ferme de voisins qui a pu étoffer
sa carte et faire quelques aménagements
nous a quand même permis il faut rester
positif de faire des travaux et des
améliorations dans l'établissement pour
recevoir les gens à nouveau de la
meilleure des façons
du côté du bar restaurant o dan pâtit la
préparation est en cours
même si certaines d'appréhension
persiste on est déjà prêt pas comme vous
dites comme on est restés ouverts tous
les
les fournisseurs tous les clients ceux
restés un petit peu au contact donc pour
ça c'était peut-être un peu plus facile
que pour des restos conduit vraiment
fermer leur frigo quand on a quelques
encore négociations à faire au niveau de
la restauration au niveau des jauges de
50% malgré ces craintes le restaurateur
vous rassure les stocks sont déjà fait
au niveau de la bière vous soyez
tranquille elle est prête pour mercredi
prochain s'il fait beau les clients
devraient donc être nombreux dès
mercredi sur les terrasses pour entamer
cette réouverture progressive jusqu'au
30 juin
avec la levée totale des restrictions
sanitaires les lieux culturels
s'apprêtent également à retrouver leur
public tout comme les enceintes
sportives les commerces et quelle sera
votre première sortie nous sommes allés
vous posez la question dans les rues de
saint quentin en yvelines
on espère pouvoir partir enfin en
vacances librement tranquillement en
espérant depuis avoir ces masques parce
que franchement
ça commence à être pesant dès que les
restaurants il ouvre la première chose
qu'on va faire c'est le faire c'est d'y
aller tout de suite quoi parce que là on
en a vraiment besoin
commencez à réfléchir de regarder des
films qui vont sortir ce que je sais pas
mais je pense que l'une des premières
choses ce sera de vouloir aller au
cinéma
peut-être profiter d'une terrasse mais
voilà ça va dépendre du temps quand même
mercredi prochain ça sera une journée
comme les autres j'espère juste
peut-être trouvé le temps d'aller me
faire un cinéma ça serait sympa comme
j'ai un petit fils que j'ai pas gâté
depuis très très longtemps
je vais essayer de lui trouver des
petits cadeaux essayer de faire vraiment
des cons aujourd'hui de confinement je
pense que je regagnerai ma famille on
ira sûrement au cinéma ou faire un
bowling ou une sortie en famille si jean
castex l'assuré nous allons vers une
sortie de crise qu'on est il réellement
de la situation sanitaire que disent les
indicateurs de lakovic 19 où en est
cette vaccination et interviews de
marion si nelly la directrice de la
délégation départementale yvelines de l'
agence régionale de santé
d'ile-de-france des propos recueillis
par grégory canale pour le taux
d'incidence au niveau régional on est
aujourd'hui à 290 cas pour 100000
habitants avec un taux de positivité à
7% et pour les yvelines
on est un peu d'incidences à 236 cas
pour 100000 habitants et un taux de
positivité à 6,9 pour cent et pour les
taux d'occupation des lits de soins
critiques en réa par les patients qu'aux
vide en ile de france on est à 125 8 9%
et dans les yvelines on est à 109 4%
donc en fait ça veut dire que au niveau
épidémiologique la situation continue à
s'améliorer on a bien une baisse de ces
indicateurs depuis plusieurs semaines
même si on reste quand même sur des des
chiffres encore assez haut et là on note
depuis trois jours une petite
stabilisation de ces chiffres ça ne
descend plus et ça reste sur ce plateau
un petit peu élevé
en ile de france on à 85% des pcr qui
sont criblés donc c'est le la petite
manipulation pour l'aîné et laboratoires
pour pouvoir avoir un séquençage sur ces
variants et aujourd'hui on est à 67 5%
de variants britannique
donc là on est sur une stabilisation et
on est à onze pour cent ne variant
brésilien ou sud-africain
et pour le coup là ça monte depuis
plusieurs semaines depuis la fin du mois
d'avril et toutes les semaines de mai en
moyenne au niveau régional en versant va
recevoir à peu près 600 mille doses donc
de façon hebdomadaire pour pouvoir
vacciner la population pour les y
viennent on a toujours nos 17 centres de
vaccination ils sont ouverts tout ce
week-end de l'ascension puisque vous
savez qu'il ya l'opération tous sur le
pont donc tout le monde joue le jeu a
ouvert des créneaux spécifiques on a
également ouvert deux centres de
vaccination éphémère ces quatre jours la
du week-end de l'ascension à magnanville
et à vernouillet lundi 17 mai on ouvre
un nouveau centre pérenne à
bonnières-sur-seine donc pour
l'intercommunalité des portes d'île de
france
hélas elle enterre cours qui n'avait pas
encore son centre le 25 mai on va
également ouvrir un nouveau centre
au chesnay et en quelques chiffres à
mercredi parce que là j'ai pas encore
les chiffres stabiliser on était à plus
de 485 milles vaccination dans les
yvelines tout cumulé injection 1 et 2
plus de 341 milles vaccination en primo
et plus de cent quarante et une secondes
injections et plus de 100000 vaccination
uniquement sur le vaccinodromes de saint
quentin en yvelines le 7-8 week end se
poursuit sur tv 78 avec maintenant notre
sélection loisirs pour les prochains
jours avant de commencer à retrouver un
début de vie normale
il va falloir encore faire preuve d'un
peu de patience célia gars de son goût
va nous en dire plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine nous allons déambuler dans
le parc du château de breteuil c'est une
nouveauté
des visites guidées sont proposées en
extérieur pour découvrir l'architecturé
des bâtiments et des jardins des images
de grégory canal et on va faire le tour
du château
on passera devant les communs mais on
n'entrera pas dedans par contre vous
vous pourrez après y rentrer on passera
également dans le jardin entre le jardin
des princes
c'est une balade d'une heure en plein
air le château de breteuil à choisel
propose une visite guidée tous les
samedi et dimanche à 14h30 et 15h30
une nouveauté pour le château qui doit
s'adapter avec la crise sanitaire les
visites intérieur n'étant pas possible
en attendant le 19 mai maintenant on est
content on a une date mais par là on ne
savait pas trop quand on allait pouvoir
ouvrir l'intérieur du château et bien en
attendant cette visite en extérieur
pouvait combler un manque
de la culture de la part de nombreux de
nos visiteurs ce jour là il était de
visiteurs à découvrir l'évolution
architecturale du château de breteuil
mais aussi de ses jardins
vers 1900 y avait des fleurs à couper
pour le château pour paris mais nice
maintenant c'est plutôt des fleurs pour
les visiteurs pour qu'ils puissent les
voir de l'époque moyenâgeuse jusqu'à la
belle époque les visiteurs peuvent
apprendre durant cette visite les
différents styles
écoutez habitants du domaine qui se sont
succédé qu'est ce qu'on a appris balle
historique des propriétaires moi j'aime
bien savoir comme salle historique
comment c'est arrivé comme ça comment le
bâtiment a évolué d'une ferme fortifiée
à ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
enfin ça ça m'a tout ce qui est
historique architectural j'aime bien
autre événement à venir au château de
breteuil une représentation de la pièce
le théâtre des contes par la troupe du
crâne dimanche 30 mai à 15h30 et 17h30
des galets caché à montigny le
bretonneux voisins le bretonneux ou
encore guyancourt une famille mini
montaigne s'est amusé pendant le
confinement à colorier des galets et les
cacher dans des lieux saint quentinois
le but du jeu les retrouver et les
cachets de nouveau regarder des mandalas
des étoiles ou encore des arcs-en-ciel
cette famille iny monteyne s'amuse à
colorier des galets plus à les cacher
dans des endroits à saint quentin en
yvelines le guet les voyageurs se fait
déjà dans plusieurs régions le but du
jeu une fois que l'on a trouvé un galet
il faut le cacher à nouveau pour qu'ils
voyagent le plus loin possible
c'est amusant ça passe le temps et c'est
on peut s'attendre à ce que les gens ils
rigolent ils s'amusent en le faisant on
a fait les arcs-en-ciel des bonhommes
on a fait des cocktails aussi et
et on a fait en fait on a fait des
mandalas on a fait plein de trucs en
fait on s'est un peu tous plus de 90
galets ont été cachés à guyancourt
montigny le bretonneux voisins le
bretonneux et elancourt le littoral n'a
pas été dénaturé
elle souhaite acheter les galets dans un
magasin de bricolage d'autres régions
font sur dans des dans des coquilles
d'huîtres vide
certaines prennent des cailloux ou tout
simplement les le gall et nous a semblé
plus plus jolie et plus facile aussi
pour dessiner parce qu'il ya un petit
peu moins d'aspérité pour l'instant une
dizaine de galles et ont été retrouvés
et se promène dans les yvelines
mais la famille iny monteyne compte
aller plus loin on a prévu pendant les
grandes vacances d'antan menées en
bretagne dans les landes enfin là où on
ira quand on sera autorisé à bouger un
peu plus loin et on incite tout le monde
à le faire aussi pour que ça se promène
partout
en attendant les vacances d'été delphine
et ses filles ont prévu de cacher des
galets à magny les hameaux plaisir et
bois d'arcy
alors ouvrez l'oeil événement sur trois
jours un mort pas mes desserts se fera
exceptionnellement cette année
100% en ligne du 14 au 16 mai l'accueil
du public aux serres municipales n'est
pas envisageable en raison du contexte
sanitaire
l'outil a verni bonsoir vous êtes
conseillère municipale déléguée à
l'embellissement de la ville à maurepas
lemay dessert a pour but de mettre à
l'honneur les services des espaces verts
de la ville
alors cette année contexte particulier
comment vous allez organiser l'événement
visio tout à fait donc cette année c'est
un événement un peu différent des autres
années puisque nous avons souhaité avoir
un mais dessert à 100% virtuel donc
ainsi monsieur robert
et le responsable des espaces verts
ainsi que son équipe en ont donc rendez
vous sur le site de la ville du 14 au 16
mai pour découvrir des vidéos et met à
l'honneur de travail des jardiniers mais
surtout c'est des ateliers de d'un
potage et une visite guidée des serres
municipales
donc c'est des vidéos qui sont à
découvrir sur notre site sur la page
facebook également et instagram
nous avons également souhaité une
distribution de plants dans les écoles
puisque mes desserts servis c'est un
événement qui est au vert aussi pour les
écoliers mais malheureusement qu ils
peuvent pas venir cette année visiter
les fermes et n'est pas tellement car on
a déplacé dans les écoles et donc voilà
c'est une autre démarche et qui va
animer les tutoriels de jardinage et du
coup donc les tutoriels seront animés
par monsieur ouvert qui est le
responsable des espaces verts ainsi que
par son équipe ont donc cédé jardé qui
travaille tous les jours pour embellir
la ville et donc ils vont prendre ça va
prend une autre ampleur donc pour une
fois ils vont devenir du coup devenir
acteur ils vont se mettre en scène pour
des petites vidéos et est ce qu'il ya un
thème cette année particulier alors donc
le thème cette année nous avons rien
c'est pas vraiment un particulier parce
que le but c'est de mettre en avant le
développement durable mettre en avant
également le travail qui est fourni
longue de tout au long de l'année donc
voilà ça serait vraiment autour de ces
pros importante pendant trois villes
habituellement il ya des conférences qui
sont organisées est ce que ce sera le
cas aussi cette année en visio alors
donc il y aura une conférence qu est ce
qu ont organisé par l'association à
femmes donc qu'il soit cube des ruches 1
qui sont situés sur la gueule de
maurepas donc ça serait pareil des
vidéos des petits pieds d'information
pour les habitants de la ville
comment reconnaître les abbés comment
faire attention bas donc c'est
principalement des vidéos sur ce mot et
les animations qui donc sont sont
destinés à quelle sorte de public est ce
qu'on doit avoir la main verte pour
pouvoir participer à mes desserts alors
donc les animations elles sont ouvertes
pour tout le public donc il n'y a pas
d'âge pour les animations et les agents
des espaces verts et se tient à
disposition de des habitants des enfants
de public et à la même verve qui n'a pas
la main verte pour pour les accueillir
et pour les renseigner et pour les aider
dans les démarches ou que c'est un
événement qui est ouvert à tout le monde
et donc j'invite j'invite tous les
habitants et les amoureux de la nature
en d'aller sur le site de la ville et de
découvrir ses vidéos et surtout ne pas
hésiter à encourager les jardiniers est
ce qu ils font un travail remarquable
tout au long de l'année
c'est un travail d'ailleurs que
je voulais souligner qui a été
récompensée l'année dernière par
l'obtention de la troisième fleur pour
la ville de mort part au concours des
villes et villages fleuris
donc voilà c'est d'attendre plus
important et c'est assez important
justement de maintenir cet événement
quand même en visio puisque d'habitude
ça se fait aux serres municipales
exactement c'est important qui est un
événement qui est très important puisque
sur un week end nous accueillons en
moyenne 3500 personnes et neuf cents
écoliers le jeudi et le vendredi
voilà autant dire que c'est un événement
incontournable des manifestations de la
ville de maurepas merci du tchad vers ni
d'avoir été notre invité oui merci à
vous pour l'invitation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour finir cette page loisirs je vous
propose une idée de sortie pour ce week
end en partant à la découverte du
quartier de la clairière de rambouillet
mais de façon insolite
dimanche 16 mai à 15h30 le palais du roi
de rome vous propose une visite de ce
quartier muni de quelques playmobil et
d'un téléphone
la balade durera 1h30 le tarif est de 6
euros par adulte et gratuit pour les
moins de 18 ans et l'émission continue
avec wilfrid pour parler de l'actualité
[Applaudissements]
oh
merci célia pour ces différents
rendez-vous nous revenons à présent
comme chaque semaine sur les faits
marquants de l'actualité des derniers
jours résumé à 78 secondes pour
l'actualité des yvelines avec mélanie
poker une élection municipale partielle
à chevreuse le dimanche 9 mai les
habitants étaient appelés aux urnes pour
élire leur maire après l'annulation du
scrutin de 2020 c'est à néry le pallec
qu'il emporte avec près de 62% des voix
plus d'ateliers philosophiques en école
primaire nadia et à signer une
convention avec l'association sève la
ministre délégué en charge de la ville
étaient pour l'occasion aux déplacements
dans plusieurs établissements trappistes
à la réserve naturelle de saint quentin
en yvelines on observe les oiseaux et on
les protège depuis 35 ans près de 230
espèces ont été recensées le site s'est
agrandie pour devenir la réserve
naturelle des étangs et rigole d'yveline
elle en rêvait rêve de seniors et le zoo
de thoiry l'ont aidé à le rendre réel
marie 70 ans habitant du tremblay sur
mauldre a fait la connaissance de ye ba
a beau temps beau et bronzé ngou les
quatre gorilles du parc les services de
réanimation des hôpitaux et cliniques
franciliens se sont vus dotés de 500
lits modulaire une enveloppe de 10
millions d'euros financés par la région
ile de france à partir de fonds
européens
plus que quelques jours à patienter
avant de rouvrir les commerces
restaurants et bars se préparent à la
reprise de leurs activités avec la mise
en place d'un protocole sanitaire
le centre commercial westfield vélizy 2
a notamment installé des capteurs de co2
l'actualité de cette semaine également
marquée par le décès de michel fourniret
le tueur en série est donc mort le 10
mai dernier à la salpêtrière à paris à
l'âge de 79 ans et on le sait assez peu
mais il avait un lien assez étroit avec
les yvelines patrice bonjour bonjour
vous allez nous en parlait justement
oui d'abord il a vécu dans les yvelines
pendant une quinzaine d'années entre peu
près entre 66 et le début des années 80
66 et juste après son retour
pratique pour juste après son retour de
la guerre d'algérie il certains disent
que la guerre d'algérie c'est très
important dans sa carrière criminelle
c'est peut-être là qu'il a commencé à
côtoyer la mort alors qu'est ce qu'ils
faisaient dans les yvelines ont ce pas
très bien et en tout cas pas au poids y
ait d'autres dans une entreprise il est
à son compte
il fabrique qui paraît que c'est un
génie de la mécanique disent beaucoup de
gens qui l'ont connu et là ils
fabriquaient des bandes coordonnées
c'est à dire des machines outils qui
permettaient de fabrique des chaussures
notamment première année il n'a pas été
inquiété par la police dont il a été une
première condamnation quand même pour
agression sexuelle en 66 mais après il
se tient le calme puisque il va pas être
inquiété jusqu'au 83 il a déjà quitté
les yvelines en 83 alors là il est
arrêté
il va il va être condamné alors il va
faire quatre ans de préventive ats qu'il
aime beaucoup il va être condamnant 87
par la cour d'assises de l'essonne à
sept ans de prison qui va alors au fait
il va être libéré très peu de temps
après le jugement puisqu'elle avait déjà
fait quatre ans de préventive mais c'est
assez important cette condamnation cette
incarcération à 10 il ya deux raisons
pour lesquelles c'est important parce
que cette à fleury mérogis qui va
rencontrer sa compagne monique olivier
il passe une annonce dans le pélerin
disent enfin danse classique un condamné
cherche quelqu'un pour rompre sa
solitude et monique olivier va le
rencontrer
elle va devenir sa femme surtout devenir
sa complice parce que celle qui fait le
guet c'est elle qui est traqué les les
victimes c'est elle qui les aident à le
cacher et probablement que sans monique
olivier la carrière criminelle de de
fournir et n'aurait pas été la même
donc ça c'est de premiers éléments
importants deuxième élément important
qui va nous ramener d'ailleurs dont les
yvelines c'est que il est y rencontre
pendant sa détention il est avec un
autre détenu qui s'appelle
si on met le breton qui est un un
braqueur vrais braqueurs qui est aussi
un militant politique puisqu'il était
proche d'action directe qu'il a fourni
des armes et elle boira ch sympathise
avec fourniret qui est pas du tout à
l'époque le monstre cynique sadique
puisque paraît quel bois je l'appelle
mon toutou donc c'est vous dire que
c'est pas de murs et et l angoisse suis
dit voilà moi et qu'il y un trésor qui
se trouve quelque part dans un dans un
cimetière du val d'oise comme tu vas
être libérés avant moi vas-y avec avec
ma compagne qui s'appelle farida
hammiche et puis récupère ce ce trésor
et ça se passera comme prévu passera
tout à fait comme prévu c'est à dire
s'il va bien aller voir farida hammiche
la compagne de 2,2 du breton de l gorge
il va bien dans le cimetière récupérer
le trésor
mais après au de le partager il aurait
dû reprendre peut-être une petite part
puisqu'elle était une sorte d'homme
demain pour récupérer ça ils
l'entraînent dans un endroit que des
bien puisqu'elle a habité rambouillet
cesser la forêt de bois de
clairefontaine
et là il étrangle farida hammiche et
récupère pour lui tout seul tous les
temps et c'est d'ailleurs le seul crime
qu'officiellement il va regretter il a
dit ben je n'aurais pas dû parce que
finalement j'avais beaucoup d'admiration
pour son compagnon bon on peut faire
autre chose qu'on entendait tenir les
gens sains mais il est d'ailleurs été
condamnés c'est sa dernière comparution
devant une cour d'assises en 2018 par la
cour d'assises de versailles à la
perpétuité pour ce meurtre
monique olivier à 20 ans pour ça pour sa
complicité
il était défendu par jacques devaux qu'à
versailles excepté greg qui s'appelle
grégory vavasseur qui était inquiété
commis d'office
concernant le lien entre fournirait le
département des yvelines ni à cette
affaire très médiatique aussi et puis il
y en a d'autres aussi où il est encore
mentionné oui alors il y à une
disparition qui a eu à manier les
hameaux dans les années 2003 alors là
bon c'est pas parce que c'est vrai que
des cas une disparition le nom de
fournir et ressurgit il n'y a pas il n'y
a pas eu de véritable lien enfin sur
cette affaire elle rit encore une autre
affaire un peu plus étonnante celle ci
on en a parlé un petit peu moins
pourtant on n'a pas parlé ça je suis
très surpris quand elle pas parler plus
c'est que dans une lettre
1004 adresse à son fils fourniret
revendique l'assassinât du ministre
robert boulin
il faut peut-être rappeler déjà un qui
était robert boulin c'était il ya
quelques années alors que les plus
jeunes on est on est dans en 1979 robert
boulin ministre du travail de giscard
d'estaing c'est un homme politique
important gaulliste historique mais qui
travaille avec giscard ce qui n'est pas
tellement au clan des chiraquiens
il est ministre du travail on parle de
lui d'ailleurs pour devenir premier
ministre à la part de la presse de
raymond barre qui n'est pas très
populaire
à ce moment-là et d'huile et embourbés
dans une affaire d'escroquerie
notre terrain qu'il a acheté à
ramatuelle où il s'est fait escroquer
par un agent immobilier un peu un peu
escroc et le 30 octobre 1979 au matin on
découvre le corps de robert boulin dans
les tons rompu de la forêt de
rambouillet alors ils vont scandale un
immense scandale de la vème république
dès qu'on découvre le corps d'ailleurs
on accuse tout de suite la presse
notamment le canard enchaîné d'avoir
fait des révélations oui c'est la presse
qui est tué robert boulin pas de chance
au bout d'un jour on retrouve une autre
lettre dans laquelle robert boulin lui
accuse plutôt le ministre de la justice
alain peyrefitte de ne pas l'avoir
soutenu
donc c'est une affaire politique et puis
il ya quand même des doutes
l'afer est démené d'ailleurs très très
mal mené l'enquêté très mal fait
probablement volontairement mal fait on
conclut très vite au suicide
la famille de robert boulin n'a jamais
cru au suicide a toujours pensé que
c'était un assassinat
pour des raisons psychologiques et pour
des raisons physiques c'est à dire qu'
il serait noyé tout seul dont 10 cm
d'eau ce qui peut constitution quand
récemment et elle épate de deux bouts
suffisamment pour pouvoir être rentré
ses chronos plein de visages alors il
faudrait que ce soit soit blessé laissez
lui même alors s'il a été tué on a en
effet des pistes pour savoir qui
pourrait être les commanditaires est ce
que c'était alors certains disent ça
peut être politique
ce serait assez étonnant mais ça peut
être en effet suite à cette cette
escroquerie
mais on n'a jamais aux faux
réfléchis acquis qui est passé à l'acte
avec qui etc et ou intellectuelle
alors est-ce que fournirait aurait fait
partie on a parlé beaucoup des barbouzes
parce que les barbus sont intervenus des
barbouzes sa veste et ses services de
sécurité qui avaient été été souvent
d'anciens truands qui était employé pour
lutter contre l' os qui voulait le
maintien de l'algérie française et il
est possible qu après son retour de la
guerre d'algérie fourniret et été plus
ou moins barbouzes de la pensée il
habitait rambouillet qu'il était pour
quelque chose dans cet assassinat en
tout cas c'est très étonnant que
personne n'a été fouillé après la lettre
de fournir et cette affaire là devraient
jamais être résolues on ne saura jamais
si fournirait ou non à était l'assassin
de l'ancien ministre il ya encore
beaucoup d'affaires non élucidées merci
patrice pour ses différentes précision
c'est la fin de cette édition du 7 8
week end les programmes se poursuivre
sur tv 78 à très bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]